Some additional considerations you'll need to keep in mind in all three cases.
First, security.
Who should have access to what?
This is important to discuss with stakeholders since
your data model can be used to access source data if you're not careful.
Second, data governance.
Data governance formalizes how data is used
and maintained based on corporate level guidelines.
They're generally in place for very good reasons to make sure that
the quality of data is good enough to support initiatives and decision-making.
Are there certain policies or approved datasets
already in place at your organization that you can use or follow?
Speaking as someone who's on a Data Governance team currently,
the people who maintain them will generally be very happy to
explain or clarify things with you to ensure consistent use of data.
Finally, are there any pre-existing data models,
flows, or other sources you could use to create your report?
This course will walk you through how to create your own data models when you need them.
But sometimes someone in your organization will have beaten you to the punch.
Powerbi.com lets you use and share data models and workspaces that you have access to.
That can save you time and provide
new opportunities to collaborate with colleagues or teams.